hello hello
everybody
[Music]
julian say cath
zombie max connor what's up my dude
brian william leon what's going on guys
what is up i guess i should put i guess
i should put this on huh
let's just test the audio real quick
sounds like everything good sounds like
everything is good
is everyone ready for zemo maybe sharon
carter i'm actually thinking sherry
carter might not be in this one
and it might just be zemo
mr anderson what is up the hero of last
stream
probably this one too
i will turn the fan off as to not
as to not put that up
so wait everybody keep saying
ri p soups is he not live i literally
talk to him today
interesting soups isn't live
uh oh
someone on super's channel commented
warren warren warren warned warren what
up bbc
um yeah let me text subs um
but let me check if um the third
episode's out
not yet okay looks like they might be
relatively on time today
yeah um 15 minutes it should start
did uh did uh
did anybody get april fool pranked today
because i got april fool's prank today
and i wasn't appreciative of it one bit
it uh i got hit hard but my sister
and her husband um they hit me really
really hard uh
they they said like his his school that
he was into
like got discredited and they had to
move
and that like my my mom's kind of with
them as well so i'm just kind of like oh
my gosh we're gonna do and then they're
like
april fools and i'm like oh my gosh why
i got freaking trolled so hard and like
i stayed off the internet today
like i didn't really i don't think i
posted on instagram i think i said like
one thing
on on twitter and then i was like
that's it
and then i got pranked outside so um
let's uh let's text soups because
um that's not good
soups actually let's call soups
i i would say let's facetime soups but
we're calling soups right now let's call
soups
it won't focus
dope thanks for the super chat
please leave me no i did not get the did
you mean to post dudes in your ig story
i know but i did get trolled pretty hard
you
good dude question mark
he i know he got a new computer um
so maybe he's having problems there um
dang i talked to brad today too and brad
said he was good to go
uh let me let me text brad
let me call brad it's only like when
it's something urgent it's always better
just to talk he's not dead oh he's sick
my man uh is soups okay i don't know
dude
i've caught him 47 times holy crap
maybe he took a nap and just didn't set
an alarm yeah i mean
he wasn't like his coffin and
[ __ ] earlier balls yeah so
but like he wouldn't
right yeah um i i'm kind of sick too
actually but i i uh i heard he was kinda
how do i go live on youtube i've never
done this before
um hold on you go to
well it's saying i need a software or
something
oh yeah you're gonna need an obs i mean
you could really quickly download
streamlabs obs
like this is insane i've never done this
isaiah solorzano happy birthday
and i can't even get disney oh really
um so
you you can download streamlabs obs it
takes like
it doesn't take long at all and then
okay so then from there you just log
into youtube
like you log into streamlabs and it'll
ask you how you want to log in and just
put it through youtube
and then so this is where it gets kind
of complicated on in the youtube studio
you have to go live and then you have to
go live
on stream labs
yeah so all you got to do is you know
connect it to stream labs
go live on youtube and then it'll say
like waiting for
you know obs to sit and so that's when
you go live on obs and that
that'll send it and then you you'll be
live
do you want to oh episode three is out
54 minutes do you want to jump
well i was gonna say do you want to jump
on a like a discord but
that won't work because i can't show it
dang it yeah
interesting um
yeah you log into youtube and you go
live
oh yeah true yeah
all right everybody get ready because
it's out as soon as we help brad
we're doing it
brad what is import obs
uh i'm not sure
this is all i know is you connect your
youtube to streamlabs obs
and then on your youtube page in the
youtube studio you click go live
and then on obs you click go live this
is crazy
yeah sorry
no you're doing great well that's all i
know how to do
uh that's literally all the advice i
think that's all i did so
no don't wait on me all right dude well
text me let me know what's up because we
can still join after
yeah all right see ya all right guys
soups and bread they're having
a tiny bit of issues we'll probably get
brad here but uh as you can see here
the episode is here it's good to go
and we're gonna start it i can't stream
the whole thing obviously but i will
show
clips and we're going if you're watching
it with me
we're going in five four three
two one there it is
we will watch the recap
they're just doing a recap right now let
me make sure stream is all going
going all right
okay cool cool we good
steve gave you that shield and you threw
it away yeah i don't
guys if we go to madrapore in this
episode i'm expecting some crazy
stuff like i'm expecting some crazy
stuff
my cats are sleeping
hello spencer bush hello
i did see godzilla vs kong today it was
cool all right here we go
credits
and we watching
the soup's live no
no all right but we're going
[Music]
yeah guys if we go to magipore today i
don't know we could see some mutants
they may not say it but we could see
some mutants holy like this could be
huge
episode five supposed to be huge but
here we go if we're
we're going right into it
the global repatriation council
society laws and borders
grc it was like a commercial for grc
reset restore rebuild jeez with the
commercials really
same thing with one division like
getting the commercials
oh here he goes where's he going new cap
look at this guy
what's he gonna do
he's munich germany
oh
need translator
oh it's the people who were harboring
them before
oh oh he's spitting captain america's
face oh he's punching him
he said do you know who i am
i do and i don't care
they just like quan i don't see your
super chat i'm sorry if i missed that
carly must be
he knows carly
does he know carly it's just new captain
hoskin oh here we go
zemo's right here right out of the gate
let's do it
right out of the gate they're going to
see zemo
he was
he said bucky's going alone he said
trust me i got it
he was obsessed with hydro we have a
history
you tell them mr anderson mr anderson
we'll time you out
there is
mr zemo
i'm sure i don't miss a text must oh
he's doing it
he's saying the code those days are over
oh look at this
that's intense
said i'm sorry it was never personal
the show is live now yes
oh zuma says i know where to begin
i wanna
so sam bucky's trying to convince sam
by the way spoiler alert we we talk
about spoilers in the in the live stream
sam is trying to convince no sorry
bucky's trying to convince sand to break
out zemo
oh yeah
you
they're breaking them up breaking them
out
interesting oh
prisoners are fighting oof
oh no way that's so cool
interesting
interesting that's pretty cool
where are we we are meeting
[Music]
somebody
hey jess you're gonna you're gonna get
you're gonna get timed out if you keep
spamming
oh the falcon
and the winter soldier episode
three uh let me tell you guys where i'm
at in the episode
uh i'm at ten minutes exactly
well that's cool
a lot of old cars that he like hid stuff
in
the mask oh
[Music]
oh
selfie selfie
selfie
apparently zemo is rich
okay
he said you've been rich this whole time
and he said i'm a baron
my family was royalty interesting
haha
oof
interesting zemo's really
that's hilarious
america super
interesting
magipore
you will have to be come someone you
claim is
gone interesting
wow this is interesting dirt so they're
going to magic
right now
i don't know why soups isn't online
right now i think he's sick
um g fuel costs anywhere between
uh 15 to 25 bucks for a tub
use code cosmic
so we're with the flag smashers now
i don't know what they're doing oh wait
wait what is this
that's an interesting symbol
seems to be her her mom or her friend or
and she's clearly she's either dying or
she's dead
here it is oh my gosh
wow that looks crazy cool what is on the
background
who is he dressed to be he said you're
gonna have to pretend to be somebody
you said was gone
look at these guys
the smiling tiger ah
that's hilarious
there is no margin for error we have to
stay in character
all right guys this is like they're
going into match report right now this
is like are we gonna see some mutants
like
i don't think they're going to tell us
our mutants but do we see them like what
happens here oh
here comes the gangs ah
so it's like you can't even like get
into madrapore this is
you know they said it's oh yeah that's
totally a gang oh that's a cool face
mask
and they got the guns they got the bike
escort
they got a mercedes very similar to mine
here we are oof nice audi
that's like an iron man out it's an r8
baby
music's cool
all right let's look for all these
easier eggs i'm gonna have to deal with
them later but
dang it everything's going so fast i'm
just gonna have to go see my scene later
they're just dealing drugs like right
outside on the street everybody's got
guns and stuff
it's kind of funny
princess bar oh there's some symbol
power broker is watching there was the
thing that said that
interesting power brokers watching
oh people know who he is
selfie oh oh that's sure carter
it had to be
so peop people know who they're
pretending to be
and they know that bucky's the winner
soldier hmm
they're cutting open a snake for a drink
they're like draining its venom and
sam's gonna have to drink it because
he's pretending to be somebody
[Laughter]
else
top
this is very
zemo's not welcome there
selfie who the heck is selfie freaking
tell me
so the power broker is there
it's a king
so in the pow the power broker is
madrapore's judge jury and
educate edu
executioner
oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho
bucky's going at it bucky's taking them
all down
but he's pretending to be the winner
soldier
and zima said winter soldier attack
because they're playing
he's they're like playing roles hey what
up mr boom boom how's it going
oh
everybody's got all the guns now
selfie will see you now
people were recording
my to my knowledge and what i've seen i
don't think i've seen
any mutant easter eggs or anything like
that
i wonder if i wonder if
we're not gonna find
find out who the power broker is
who's selfie about to be introduced
spoiler alert
oh
interesting
hmm
tell us what you know about the super
soldier serum
and i'll give you the winter soldier
along with the code words to control him
huh super soldier mr match board
he worked on
i know that name
and he was a us he is the person
responsible for
isaiah bradley
interesting sam got a phone call she
told him to answer it on speakerphone
i'm interested
yo come around
oh crap they're made kill them oh she
just got
shot it's definitely gotta be
that's sharon carter
oh she'll be dead
i don't know how much that bounty was
worth but
oh there's a bounty on all of them
oh snap oh snap
i can't run in these hills falcon says
interesting
oh yeah that's totally sharon carter
she's sniping people out helping them
out
boom
ah look who it is
dang
she's still on the run dang
this isn't over
dang look at that's crazy so sharon
because she stole captain america shield
and then
she stole falcons wings she
got in trouble for sokovia cords and she
went on the run
and she didn't have the avengers
to back her up so she's still on the run
we're in the crazy place now
interesting
i'm hosting clients in an hour
what the hell sharon do
oh how's the new cap
dang
hmm
sharon said to stay away from it
wilfred nagel
works with power broker yeah
dang
that's true that's true
he said they cleared uh bucky you know
the winter soldier killed all these
people
we can definitely clear your name hmm
stay out of trouble and of course
they're gonna go to a club
dang
well there was a tablet that had
something on i'll have to go back and
take a look at what that's let's look in
here i don't see any like crazy easter
eggs or mutants right here
they're just the club we've seen the
scene you know in the and the trailers
they're just walking around
she jama's dancing that's hilarious
found who
okay so now they're going to the docks
like we've seen before
nagel's in there so they're actually
going to go talk to dr
nagle inside of one of these containers
dr nagel in the comics is responsible
for taking the 300 african-american
americans and turning them or and
putting them on
giving them serum sorry i'm trying to
watch and talk at the same time
they're just an empty thing now empty
uh crate
that's where the doctor's supposed to be
it's gonna be like a secret passage or
something
well there it is secret door secret door
legit all right so they're going in to
talk to this doctor
i mean this could very well be the
weapons plus program right here
dr nagle oh look at that
interesting
wait no that can't be him
oh you know who he is right
intense
oh they have company people are coming
uh oh oh she's beating them up oh she's
going at it look at that oh
that's epic that's epic
now they're doing this guy who created
the super soldier serum
she's fighting some more people's she
said every bounty hunter in the city is
here looking for them they gotta go
oh she just stabbed that guy oh she just
threw a knife at that guy
oh
wow punch them in the balls dude
there you go girl she got him she got
him
break that up
isaiah
he did
oh he changed the serum a little bit
oh
interesting
power broker again
carly morgenthaus stole those
donya madani
zemo now has a gun he found a secret gun
meanwhile sharon carter is still
shooting people i should say stabbing
people
oh geez she's killing it literally
killing them
oh geez she's just like stabbing people
left and right up now she shot
some my dude your legs
oh dang she's killing it holy crap dude
he killed yeah oh
that's not good
oh they're in trouble now
oh that's not good everything is
literally flammable that place is about
to blow
up
yep and there it goes
they fighting
oh we're getting into it now guys lots
of shots fired
boom boom boom we've seen these parts in
the trailer before
and zemo is gone
woof
oh nope he's still there we're running
away oh there's the mask
here it is
oof
that's awesome look at this guy here
goes emo
zemo's crushing it holy crap with the
mask on
what the thanos mask
it's a great episode holy crap i like oh
snap
oh no oh
no that's intense
interesting what is happening
ha seema got a card
ah share card is gone
ha say i've got in the back seat
behind buggy and he said you're not
going to move your seat up are you
direct who's this
why is she like she's like famous in
mattrepor or something
but uh falcons said you're not gonna
move your seat up are you buggy said no
that's from the uh
that's from the uh civil war
so i'm at 39 minutes
this episode is 54 minutes long
these guys are talking
hmm
now
yep
interesting
oh they're at the grc
oh back
back with these guys
mentioning isaiah again
they're just talking again
interesting
but he said we need a new cap
and i want to take it back
they found madani dead dang it
uh people keep talking about carly like
she is somebody but
she's like a kid to me it looks like i
mean
oh is this the scene where
they keep talking about like this
vaccine
but like for what
like what what is like diseasing people
after the snap
like that's some they failed to tell us
that
oh they blew that place up
oh
[Music]
interesting
wait
whose memorial is it well bucky chose
not to go with them so
what the heck did he just pick up
does anybody know what that little
signal is oh these things are everywhere
that some what is that symbol bucky's
finding like these little tiny
balls that seemingly have trackers in
them
you drop something
ah no
[Music]
interesting
well that explains why a bunch of people
kept saying that well geez now i
understand
oh my cat's in here well that's crazy
that obviously makes sense why she's
there for him
and sam even mentioned that um
let's look let's watch the post credits
together everybody
and see if we can find
i can't remember the name of that
freaking gang that that symbol is for
oh i don't know chinese i can't
translate that
smashers
[Music]
i have to go through i just have to go
through this frame by frame it's like
literally the only way i can do this
oh gosh guys i'm tired
dang
well dang oh hello christopher
no not the whole time i just show clips
every now and then just to keep the
people entertained
that's what we do we entertain people
let's
let's
so something i'm confused about
gosh there's so much credits hold on is
there a post credit
yeah there's not a post credit i'm gonna
have to go through and oh that's cool
um
hello um okay let me
let's get a zoom going
i did not get that one no soups like
started a stream extremely late
have a good night man thanks for joining
uh it was really cool like you were
watching along with me and it was cool
to get your input and
you were right about sharing so good on
you i do have a zoom length and i will
forward it to you
but it's not going to work until he gets
it
i love it i think he's still watching it
right now so i mean he's going to be
late
yeah we gots to get the works done
yeah he's only 16 minutes into it
um so it looks like it's just going to
be us today
he's 45 minutes behind cody
yeah we're doing our we're doing our
stuff here
i have to get up so early tomorrow and i
have to work all night tonight so we're
just gonna jump into this discussion
um how do i
what did we do last time how did i see
you i just pulled up your stream i guess
so you know what i don't understand
is they're like they they
the flax masters are like stealing like
medicine and like
apparently like a back scene right what
is that for
like what i think it's just for people
in this refugee camp i don't think
they're bad guys at all
i mean she murdered a bunch of people in
a building at the end
kind of corrupt right right
it was a surprise to him yeah she's kind
of like really like
diving into the whole
well this is like inception i'm going to
have you here like
in me and you know man
yup oh no just do this
let's get you bigger
20 vials 20 super soldiers
she said what
i can't hear i can't hear chris anymore
huh chris can you hear me i can't hear
chris anymore
um
dang that's so it's so crazy because oh
you can't hear chris
whoops you should be able to know
um he's not talking now but uh
maybe the vast seems like a node to like
real life right because like
there's the vaccine coming out or out
already you know people are getting
stuff like that
um yeah i can't hear chris this is a
is weird but my stream is still up right
am i i'm i fear i'm losing internet
is my stream still up my stream's still
up
okay i don't know no idea
but uh oh you know what i can do i can
do this over here
but i i i think
i don't know if it's for anything
specific maybe they're just taking
supplies to like help people but people
seem to know who she
is so i'm very curious as to see
[Music]
um
i'm very curious just to see like who
she is and why she knows people
hello christopher
hello are you there
what is happening i am here oh there we
go now i can hear you okay yes
i believe the rest of the stream can
hear you now as well
oh cool maybe i don't know
do we hear it yeah we couldn't hear each
other jake but we can now
i can hear him can you guys hear him you
should be able to hear him for sure on
my side
and i'm gonna put him oh yeah 100 they
hear you on my side
i checked it they should be able to hear
you all right much better conversation
please let me frickin select this i
swear nothing wants to work for me today
like that nothing once it works nothing
wants to work for me okay
uh chris you are going to remain a tiny
little man in the corner of my screen
that's okay i'll be a tiny one man that
doesn't matter
uh yeah i don't know if that if that
if that means anything power broker big
big
so many name drops in this one um
what if the power broker is sharing i
was kind of thinking that i was like
how is sharon so powerful so powerful
and madrapore
um now it doesn't sound like she got
snapped
nope um
it doesn't sound like she got snapped
and it you know a lot of people did
so maybe i mean maybe she's the power
broker's
wife but she's more than capable of well
she wants to go home
right i'm still gonna lead towards
thunderbolt ross as the power broker
i personally think it's thunderbolt rise
it all adds up in my mind do we know if
he was snapped or not
no but hold on let me check my audio
all right you're good okay no so here's
here's my deal
if he wasn't snapped if if
if ross wasn't snapped just think about
how easy it would be
for him to come into power that's what
i'm saying
if he wasn't snapped easy for him to
just dip into modern poor you know and
be like hey
i'm gonna be in charge because screw the
us government it's gonna be nowhere in
the last 15 20 years
bucky was kicking some butts malik
what's up is sharon carter the power
broker like
i mean i wouldn't be surprised and i
wouldn't be upset she is insanely cool
right now her entire character is
completely true
i feel okay no here's here's my deal
here's my deal
if she was the power broker i don't
think all these people would try to kill
her
this is accurate but maybe nobody knows
who the power broker actually that's
what i was thinking
you know because nemo was even like i've
only heard about who who he is
right and that's gonna be like a big you
know oh it's actually sharon this whole
time but nobody knows because nobody's
actually met them
but that was a thought i had a theory
going into it that maybe zemo was
somehow the power broker
but i don't think he popped it
zego was awesome
[Applause]
such a cool character yeah bucky talking
about
we need a new captain america and
yeah he said he was gonna kill the
shield sam talking about destroying the
shield
and he's like i'm gonna steal it before
you destroy it like
it's interesting so they're doing a lot
of callbacks
this episode was fantastic just throw
that out there there was another wakanda
reference right yeah yeah so sam
was talking about you know what zemo
means to wakanda
you know they didn't forget it was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it this was a more serious episode but
it had some funny
it had some funny tones a lot of action
but a more serious episode oh i didn't
realize this was in the way sorry
um that's crazy
is zemo going to be an anti-hero um if
he becomes part of the thunderbolts
the 100 yeah so i think from here on
yeah
so so here hear this hear this um
it's thunderbolt ross it's power broker
zemo falcon bucky sharon they all work
their way
they take down the flag smashers they
like get to the power broker
i don't know how it would go but then at
the end that's when thunderbolt ross is
like gazebo broke out of jail
but if you work for me i can make you
free
you know i'll keep you out blah blah
blah blah thunderbolts get formed
right so
the serum is clearly a huge part of this
um
right right right that's the connecting
piece uh
uh thunderbolt ross has always been by
the way i have a
falc of a captain america fidget spinner
hey hey i gave that to you so um no
thunderbolt ross is always like
that's his like a fixation right like
that's it's the serum for him creating
an abomination
like doing all so like clearly i'm not
shocked at all if he shows up i'm not
shocked at all if he's the power broker
a little shocked but excited if sharon
carter is power broker i'm not sure
about that one
uh i think she's gonna have some
connection if she isn't
she definitely knows who the power
broker is i think there's no way she's
hosting these mega parties with all this
art and stuff and she doesn't have some
type of connection she
she she there's no way you can be that
big in madrid without the power broker
because the power broker is the king
right the judge jury executioner is what
she said
so there's no way you can be as big as
sharon
and not know who the power broker is the
power bugger is going to know who you
are
right exactly and you don't really get a
choice if the power broker wants to meet
you right exactly
so
man she very well could be the power
broker i mean
i wouldn't be surprised it seems like
something marvel would want to do right
now
it seems like the direction they would
be okay with heading
and um could be part of the reason why
she doesn't want to come back and maybe
she's ready to dip and leave all that
stuff behind
i don't know why she would want the
super soldier serum
that yeah that that's a that's a
different thing
unless unless her getting the super
soldier serum
was how thunderbolt ross was going to
give her her pardon
oh chris did you nail it on the head
right there
right she wants her pardon she can't get
back to the united states she hasn't
talked to her family that's all she
wants
thunderbolt ross said in black widow or
something like that at some point get me
the serum
it's all yours come back to america meet
your family i think that's it
whoa i think i think the pieces have
just come together
i think subscribe to cosmo culture
subscribe to cosmic culture for sure
subscribe to chris guys um
guys child's not gonna die in the mcu
they're not gonna they're not gonna show
them dying
for all the people saying that they're
our king lives on you know our king went
to the astral plane so you know
something like that um they're not going
to show him dying
marvel's not going to do that chadwick
was too loved by everybody
yeah they're just not going to do that
but absolutely
daniel diaz charlotte's going to be
episode 5 thanks for super chat but i
don't think so
good question from cody here do you
think walker will get the serum i think
he's going to steal it i think sorry
i've got it
i think she mentioned at some point that
they haven't drank them all they're
going to use that
to get to the power broker so they can
get the help they need for the refugees
so we don't know how many but there are
some left
i think at some point john walker is
going to
get to them get to the serum and his ego
which is the biggest driving force he
has
yeah which is really annoying clearly
so he's going to be like i'm just as
good as real captain america he's just
gonna chug it and
you know we'll see what that that's
where i'm leaning towards obviously it's
just a guess but
um well
so going back to the thunderbolt ross is
the power broker
and even if he's
if he's not the power broker maybe he's
in charge of the grc
but i mean he's connected in it he's
some third party
right there's no way he is let's see
let's say
i personally think walker already has it
because when they were showing him
last episode like throwing the shield
and doing all the stuff
like if you if you think about timeline
like he had the shield and was doing all
that stuff already but sam just gave up
the shield
right and he's like jumping and like
doing all the stuff and like that
right and when he was talking with the
good morning america person during the
interview she was talking about
like his body and stuff like that but
those tests couldn't have like those
tests had to be done very recently
because they're like showing him
performing everything with the shield
and that's in a very short time span
because the first episode is when
falcon gave it up and it's the same
shield right
so i mean i think he probably got some
version of it
now do i think maybe
some of those serums weren't taken like
all 20 weren't taken because
some have to get back to john walker or
some have to get back to ross right
yeah that makes sense um because what
seven super soldiers right now
um one died when the power brokers men
showed up in the first episode he pushed
down the pole
and he got shot right so six
left and that means 13 vials left
theoretically is that what you guys are
saying oh we're rating the episode just
kidding
um yes so there was for seven
there's 13 vials left
um i mean they're gonna be used
right they have a specific purpose if
they're not
all used the power broker
[Music]
i mean if share sharon carter knows
a lot and
again she seems to be in power
she's not a weak person she's someone
she's someone important and
she is someone important in madrid
and and you know what that makes her a
huge source of information for
all of that stuff she's like alley cat a
source of information she's a source of
information
um
yeah and a lot of people know carly
which i'm very confused about
like carly morgenthau like
isn't she just like this girl like i
guess she was in madrid as well
so maybe she did something and oh you
know what i think it's kind of all
adding up together because you know
it's clear that sharon carter is
somebody very important to magic for
carly used to be in madrid
and then she kind of went rogue is what
it sounds like
so you know if she was somebody in magi4
she definitely probably knows sharon
carter
um sharon carter said we had a problem
when she was getting to her car after
the after the scientist died
okay so maybe her problem is i'm trying
to get the super soldiers
oh yeah yeah we got a problem in fact
we've got a few of them so yeah maybe
and that's why she was so reluctant to
go with them and she's just like yeah go
get me your pardon
so whether she's like completely turned
or she's using
her position to get a head somewhere in
some type of life
there's definitely there's definitely
more with sharon than than we're being
there's a lot more to sharon
than oh a lot we're allowed to do you
know what's really weird oh hold on let
me acknowledge the super chat yeah yeah
yeah rachel knight online not gonna lie
as soon as i heard the name
yeah no i know madani yeah you were
thinking from dina but it was like
dania right he said or something like
that it was a little different
um from the punisher i don't know
if it's the same i i don't think so
because kevin feige seems pretty adamant
on really not making those canon like
they weren't under the direction of him
you know like he wasn't really involved
with them
uh now everything that's produced on
disney plus he is like he's the main guy
so
it looks like kevin feige is pretty
adamant on
i like really not keeping those cannon
mama jazzy what is up
always in the chat you don't think ross
power broker
um works with us plain sight i doubt
he'll appear in the series must be
someone new
thank you for that super chat um thank
you for all the ones in the past yeah i
mean you make a good point there
um my whole deal is is just his
connection to the super soldier serum
is like really big um and that's why
i think it's him you know um because
it's just it's just such a huge
connection
and the serum such a prominent factor
here and then he's gonna be in black
widow and i believe the serum is gonna
be a big
part to play there as well uh we know
they have the red vials
so it's kind of like i don't know i just
feel like if the super soldier serum is
like out there he
he's there he's there uh sa saji johnson
or sahih johnson
i'm so sorry if i pronounced that wrong
i noticed it showed sam's family boat
then zemo and the end credits maybe zemo
takes off in the boat
and wakanda ain't playing well god ain't
playing yeah i was i was like those
little beads look so familiar
and i couldn't figure it out and then
obviously when
when she showed up and then i was like
duh so
it's crazy you know they're gonna want
zemo obviously she said that
but uh because he killed zemo killed
t'chaka
you know he killed the king of wakanda
before t'challa black panther was
black panther i mean they want him
uh but maybe maybe zema takes off in the
boat um when i talked to the director
and chris this is what i was gonna say
when i talked to the director carrie
skaglin
i asked her about zemo she said he's not
going to do what you expect him to do so
therefore i think he might actually be
good but when i talk to her about sharon
carter
all she really said is she's like bad a
like she's
awesome so there's something there she
didn't give me much about
sharon carter and i even like pressed a
little bit more
right like she gave me a little bit
she's like oh we're gonna see right
we're gonna see what's
so this could be like this really could
be a huge
a huge like like just twist
sharon carter could be i think she's
obviously someone important
oh yeah yeah and she did what she had to
do like in madrid
but she's clearly wealthy there right
and people i think i'm gonna go as far
to say that she is the power broker
i think i think for sure she's the power
broker i like the idea of her trying to
get the super soldier serum to get her
pardon but that seems
kind of my new when you're like a queen
of an entire civilization i mean maybe
she just embraced it you know
yeah i think and maybe it started off
that way and she's like i got more power
than i expected and
right and now yeah hey sparky how you
doing
geez yes sir jesus thank you for that
super chat just finished it so good then
it gave me goosebumps especially with
the music love the content hey super
appreciate that yeah that ending was uh
unexpected and they didn't drop the
white wolf and stuff like that
but uh i didn't expect someone from
wakanda to show up but if i think about
it now it's like they broke zemo out of
course
wakanda people are going to want to kill
zemo he killed t'chaka
they're king uh so yeah we don't know
who that was that sharon talked to
after the fight we just know that that
is i think the
little tiny breadcrumb trail they're
lining up for us like hey there's more
to this character that's that's
essentially what that was well the fact
that sharon
said we have a problem after the guy
died like what could her problem be
like right right right right and the
problem is bucky sam and zemo are
running around causing problems
right that's the problem uh cam k thanks
for that super chat yes or no
do you think the power broker someone
we've seen before in the mcu or a new
character
i'm kind of thinking that sharon carter
at this point
i mean i didn't when we got here but
we've talked ourselves into this so i'm
sticking with it i've talked myself into
this
and i don't want it to be like oh
mephisto thing
i just think based on what we saw
she is the power broker she went on the
run it was very interesting the way like
they talked about her story
i i actually liked it you know like i
stole the shield
first for steve right then i stole your
wings to give to you so you could help
him
right but i didn't have avengers backing
me up i didn't have a team backed me up
i had to go on the run
right so she went to like the like sin
city pretty much right like the city of
pirates where
you know everything is uh yeah
well comic exposed thanks for super chat
but definitely going to disagree with
you on that one i think it was a pretty
good episode
uh i liked it i liked the action in it
it was more of a serious tone
you know uh fewer comedic
scenes and uh it was pretty serious i
like zemo a lot i think zemo really
really zemo and sharon actually made the
episode for me i
you know falcon one more um bucky was
great but zemo and sharon actually made
the episode for me one more immediate
thought you know and this isn't to
take away from sharon's newfound
abilities to just be a completely
amazing and hand-to-hand combat
but it's possible she's had some super
serious soldier mission district
development right and she's very capable
as we're seeing and
that could be a part of it you know
that's like i mean she took on like 35
people on her own you know
right well let's think about this they
did say
the doctor did say that
he designed the serum differently to
where it doesn't like make your body
grow and like huge like steve rogers
like
right right so you we can't tell now
right because these
it's not like the small person like
original steve becoming like this huge
buff
person it's something now you can't tell
right
so maybe i mean yeah no that's i mean if
she's a power broker she had access to
it for sure oh for sure
i mean i think she had access to it
regardless um seems like it right rachel
knight online thanks for that super chat
i actually like this thought
lol imagine the power broker is justin
hammer that would be hilarious
i would love that i i i would
i think that would be so funny i would
love to see chris what are we talking
about today
sam rockwell looking it's